ancient and every one of you ride an  individual by  [Music]  again we're not trying to point out a  wall bikes better than another but that  all these bikes are completely different  abs truly comes into its own when the  surface changes so for example if I go  over some gravel or some grits  the ABS can actually help me stay  upright and help me keep in control of  the bike allowing me to stop safely  if I didn't have abs one or both of the  wheels could possibly lock up in those  situations and then I can lose control I  could even come off the bike or drop the  buy  we've just been doing some emergency  braking practice and they use backed out  of a driveway right in front of me and I  just sit up straight I stopped about 18  inches from the passenger door he hasn't  seen me at all  now I know that if I hadn't just been  doing that practice it would have been  different I would have probably smacked  into him convinced about this  [Music]